here's the big news today we're all
waiting eagerly to hear about the
potential indictments it was presumed
that Trump would be indicted on
something related to January 6 but
instead this is the most ironic and
hilarious thing the Daily Mail reports
Trump accused of trying to delete the
Mar-A-Lago server and wipe surveillance
footage in bombshell new indictment
ex-president hit with more charges and
head of clubs maintenance is also
implicated in classified documents case
the long story short of it Trump
apparently told some guy he wanted uh as
they say the former president allegedly
told aids to wipe security footage from
his Florida Club server as a way to foil
investigators probing the removal of
classified documents from the White
House see that's an opinion statement
they're making an accusation just
because Trump wanted a server with
security footage wiped doesn't mean he
intended to commit a crime by doing so
because it's been like oh we're gonna do
a routine like wipe of the servers but I
digress Carlos D Oliveira mar-a Lagos
head of Maintenance has been named as
the third defendant alongside the former
president and his valet Walt NADA both
developments present additional legal
Jeopardy for the former president who
spent uh part of Thursday blah blah just
imagine this Imagine This
we've it's been years since they
outright said they will not indict
Hillary Clinton for actually deleting
public record
for having phones smashed with hammers
so you're sitting there as Trump and
you're like we're totally allowed to do
this Comey himself said it okay well you
know wipe the server I guess oh nope now
they got you now you're now you're going
to be criminally charged and arrested
sounds like they're having it I it
actually feels like they're having fun
that they are like you know let's just
get them let's get Trump on what what
Hillary didn't get on it'll be just just
desserts for Donald Trump I don't know
if that's true it's hard for me not to
look at it and think you know now that
they're arresting his head of
Maintenance in his valet they're trying
to make him feel guilty for putting
Regular People In Harm's Way like they
are trying everything to get him to take
a plea deal to sort of bow down to this
it seems kind of sick
man I just was singing to Hillary When
Donald Trump was on stage with her and
he was like you'd be if I was President
you'd be in jail they just you never
forget they never forget one of the best
debate moments in modern history I think
that's the reason why they're putting
trying to put him in jail right now
because they're like you do not do that
to the Democratic party in public you do
not say those things directly to Hillary
Clinton Public unless you want to face
the Wrath is like what this feels like I
mean it just Republicans sit around
doing nothing and Democrats are lobbying
Molotov cocktails figuratively and
literally in New York they quite
literally did and now they're trying to
arrest Republican electors they're
charging them with felonies they're
indicting Trump again they're going
after his maintenance guy I just it just
kind of feels like the Republican party
is sitting there going
oh no or they're they're in on it
they're they're what can they do
Republicans exactly so in uh say a
Republican state like West Virginia
where you have Republican DA's they can
start criminally charging Democrats
they can say hey hold on there a minute
you just fight
fight fire I mean is it fighting fire
with fire I mean is there when it comes
to say like Hillary Clinton Barack Obama
Joe Biden do any of the crimes they've
committed extend to the jurisdiction of
these conservative or republican or even
in some cases like Republican
libertarian uh counties or districts the
answer is of course yes absolutely Joe
Biden for instance there was already
talk from Republicans about potentially
bringing charges against Joe Biden
because if he's operating out of certain
territories or certain areas I mean a
lot of these people have property in
Florida right Rhonda santis and the
Florida DA's could be going after people
but not a single not a single ba not a
single Republican anywhere has come up
with any reason or has found any crime
committed look but they are they're like
um isn't Congress about to impeach Biden
so they're kind of throwing back they're
not they're not nope no they say that
like uh Kevin McCarthy said this may
reach the level of an impeachment
inquiry okay okay so so I just heard
that like two days ago and and they say
say these things so that you hear
they're going to impeach Biden when what
he actually said is we might ask the
question should Biden be impeached we
may think about it we might like like
they're not even asking should Biden be
impeacher saying you know if this keeps
happening we might have to ask each
other if this reaches a level of
impeachment I mean I think you asked a
good question what do we do or what do
people do in general how do you fight
back against the machine I don't well
understood is to do just Judicial System
right that's you would think so but then
I see Sam Beckman freed released today
from his charge and he's walking on his
10 billion dollars and he said he's
going free Hillary Clinton didn't get
charged for emails James Comey said she
did nothing wrong Hunter Biden had a pat
on the wrist of course that may be no
longer the case with some of the charges
maybe being put back on the table
um but it feels like using the legal
system to disrupt the people that are in
at the top of the legal system isn't the
best method so how do we how how do I
mean I like to make culture building
culture so yeah yeah well we went
through this because we were sued by
Disney and we learned pretty quickly
that fighting the lawsuit with Disney in
Los Angeles
is not a place you want to be
so we were handed all kinds of crazy
crazy like our trial
um for example
we had a someone who was going to come
testify from Google that we had gone to
work with Google to try to get licensing
to be able to skip stuff in in TV shows
and movies and the judge said last
minute this person can't test them one
enough right morning enough and those
those decisions are decided 30 days in
advance yep and then and then after that
the judge lets Disney testify Google's
motives they with their expert so crazy
crazy stuff and uh and so we just
decided we've got to get out of court as
fast as we possibly can and fight in the
marketplace that's one place where we
feel like we still can fight and uh we
settled in uh 2020
and um and our company you know when we
were sued we did like 8 million and um
and here we are we have a formerly
Disney film that uh is winning in the
market it's like 130 million people that
don't know about your lawsuit did you
really quickly explain like what was a
lawsuit or what what's public about it
so the way that we started Angel Studios
is 10 years ago four brothers and a
cousin we had young kids
like nine and under and we wanted to
watch really great compelling stories
but have them match values like my
nine-year-old I didn't want him to go
and speak to his sisters in certain ways
when they were young and so we created
this technology that would allow you to
skip you know Skip certain language or
skip nudity or whatever
and um and we thought if we launched
this technology we're going to collect a
group of people who care about
storytelling and care about family and
then we'll be able to then we'll be able
to distribute
news stories to these people better than
Hollywood can so that was that was the
original Vision so we built the the
filtering technology the skipping
technology
uh 2016 it started to succeed and then
we got sued and then uh 2020 we settled
and then we pivoted to during that
lawsuit we pivoted to creating our own
stories you you said you settled for 8
million is that what you said it was
like 7.8 uh uh uh so it was a 62 and a
half million dollar
um judgment and they basically said
we'll forgive that if you'll pay for
some of our legal fees and uh and we
settled in 2020. so our thought process
was
after fighting for four and a half years
and Disney had probably spent they'd
spent tens of millions of dollars trying
to destroy an angel
and we had spent millions of dollars
trying to fight back it was just we got
to get out of their game
we can't fight inside of the system well
and they cannot send you that's one of
the challenges and the whole entire
Hollywood System knows that this
downtown LA court they call it the bank
like they call it like it's called the
bank because you can just take anybody
there and get money out if you're a
Hollywood studio and so the the
and and we we actually got hit really
hard by Disney and so there there was
this this moment where you're just
realizing
you can't fight them on their ground we
just gotta opt out of this system
and build an entire parallel
uh Studio system to the current
Hollywood system or else we can't we
can't rise up through their system and
so how did you so people don't know you
guys the harman Brothers do commercial
work too you guys have done a lot of
like The Squatty Potty stuff you did the
the rainbow poop coming out of the
Unicorn yeah commercial iconic so did
you take your like private money and
then you were able to rebuild after the
settlement or like how did you come back
from it basically because I think a lot
of people might think you get grounded
to dust just yeah well I mean we
understood yeah and we don't know of a
company who's a startup that has
survived from a Disney lawsuit so we we
feel very grateful but
um one thing that happened is we had two
major successes while we were in
bankruptcy through going through the
lawsuit dry bar comedy which gets over a
billion views a year it's stand-up
comedy that's funny for everyone
um and then the chosen which is like a
top five TV series
um and
we just started growing like crazy
during this lawsuit and uh and then
Disney and and then we had a trustee
during the bankruptcy who was in charge
of her company we had to file bankruptcy
yes but yeah to protect us from Disney
there's a chapter 11 bankruptcy has this
format where you can actually use it as
a shield against a predator so we used
bankruptcy to protect us from Disney yes
and and then
um
uh as soon as they as soon as the
trustees saw how fast we were growing
with this parallel system that we were
building
he said to the judge these guys are
going to be able to pay off the entire
62 million dollars and Disney said wait
wait a second we actually don't want to
be paid back we just you know just put
them into chapter seven yeah just put
them into chapter seven and the judge is
like oh you guys aren't acting your own
financial interest I can't trust you
anymore
um why didn't they want to be paid back
because they wanted they wanted us dead
they wanted us chapter seven is a
liquidation they wanted all our assets
sold off they wanted the judge to say
you don't have 62 million today so sell
everything off and then and then we get
what's what's left but the but the
trustee said no these guys are growing
so fast they're going to be able to pay
off this whole 62 million dollars I just
need a plan plus interest wow and
Disney's like no that's not what we want
and uh wow this is like no thank you
please please no they're like no we
don't want to be paid off and the judge
is like why the whole point of chapter
11 bankruptcy or chapter 7 is you're
supposed to want to get paid back not
just destroy a company right and so he
said I'm not going to let you do that
and then he threw it out or what no no
no then Disney said no okay we'll settle
if you guys won't ever use your
technology to filter our stuff again
we'll we'll forgive the 62 million you
guys pay you know part of our legal fees
part of the legal fees and uh and we'll
call it good we just went we like I said
like Jeffrey said that we have a hundred
thousand people who have invested who
who helped make the content decisions we
went to our investors and we said guys
we told you we'd fight this all the way
we have this chance that we can just go
after original storytelling instead of
skipping over Hollywood stuff we make
our own stuff we tell our own stories
and we control those stories what do you
guys want to do do you want to fight
this all the way or do you want to tell
our own stories and 84 of our people
said let's just go tell the stories and
then we offered to buy out the rest of
them did you get inspired during the pro
the court process to start your own
storytelling so actually we thought
about doing our own storytelling at the
beginning that's the only reason
Jeffrey's involved yeah I told Neil when
he came to me Neil and Jordan came to me
and they were like let's build this
system that skips and mutes content in
movies and I was like uh that happened a
while back and everybody there's like 14
companies that did this and every single
one got sued out of existence but how
what's the what's the ground's pursuing
um it's copyright copyright arguments
but it seems weird because if I had a
movie on at home and I skipped it that's
not copyright but if you have a
technology that does it because the
technology uses there's a there's a a
law called The Family movie Act of 2005
that allows you to skip and mute content
that's transmitted
over the Internet we read that and said
that means as long as the customers
bought the content and as long as they
make the choices then as long as they're
making the choices then we can provide
technology to skip and mute content
Disney came in and said no the dmca
you're you're you're decrypting oh what
I don't you know well that Neil can
explain it better I think the best way
to explain it was this the ninth circuit
basically said we see vid Angel's
argument
that was your company yeah our company
at the time was called vid angel that
sounds like a good thing we see it this
is a novel interpretation a lot we also
see Disney's argument and it just so
happens if we go with vid Angels there's
a big hole in copyright law
yeah so we can't do that we're gonna go
with Disney and and we're like wait a
second The Family movie Act was like an
exemption under copyright law what you
know that's what they mean it is a whole
it's designed it's designed to be an
exemption but but we weren't going to
win in in in in that Court we weren't
going to win in that system what if you
open source technology and just release
it to the wind
we actually uh we actually did set up a
foundation in the middle of the lawsuit
and announced that and Disney came
screaming to the courts and saying that
they that they needed to seize the
company from us uh before we uh let any
assets out of the company so because
that was ultimately what's that they
stop you from doing it well we were just
asking the court if they would let us do
it and the Disney stopped
wait so you're saying the technology
which seems completely honest in today's
day and age not pretty simple pretty
simple yeah is is not available I mean
there's got to be open source versions
of this so we settled and we sold vid
Angel yeah off and it still works you
can you can it just doesn't work for
Disney's it just does not work for
Disney or Warner Brothers yep it's like
two of the biggest producers of
children's content that they would maybe
want to use this for yeah yeah so hold
on this is but it's doing well you can't
run a plug-in on your own browser
watching movies is that what it is
yeah so you you you can
um but you can't but you can't do it as
a modern streaming device so you can't
do it through your iPad you can't do it
through your Roku all iPhone all those
things that's what that's a VHS you can
do it on a browser you could do it like
through a Chrome browser with an
extension but you can't get it on an
iPhone or something because it would
have to
oh my modern device you wouldn't be able
to do it with I guess technically if you
use Chrome on your phone to watch which
would not be as good as this is the
streaming app Chrome on your phone
doesn't support extensions
right so so so what you're saying is the
thing that you made actually would go
between an app yeah it would basically
it would basically go like if you have
your Netflix account you tie your
Netflix account to vid Angel and it
would go and it would be you you'd make
your choices you'd say oh I want to skip
nudity and then it would go up and it
would in the cloud it would contact your
Netflix account
get your Netflix stream
it and send it down to your you know
your iPhone or free to your Roku or
whatever and that you know that's the
only way it could be done on a modern
streaming device and you know for it was
like 14 of the market is on a desktop
and you know uh uh 86 of the market at
the time was all on streaming devices so
that's how we delivered the technology
right right well I I get it I get it
yeah when you guys settled and then you
bounced did you bounce out of California
after that are you still sticking around
Cali we're in Utah okay so were you were
never based in California that's just
where the lawsuit happened yeah so what
happened you after you settled like what
was the what was the impetus for the the
next generation of Harman
of Angel Studios yeah yeah so we after
we settled we we bought angel.com and
then we rebranded as Angel Studios
um you know Angel Bean investor and uh
dry bar we had the chosen yeah then we
just started expanding Tuttle twins
which you can see I'm sporting right
here
um the wing feather Saga which is
fantasy Tuttle twins is like a freedom
education thing for kids Ron Paul right
yeah yeah
it fit in that world yeah um and then
you've got
um
sound of Freedom now which is fun
because we went through all this battle
and and fox was acquired by Disney
during our lawsuit and this parallel
story was happening and then we ended up
with the rights to sound of Freedom here
in 2023. Fox paid for sound of freedom
to get made is that how it worked and
then Disney bottom so Disney owned it
yep yep and they were suing you when you
bought it from them or did you wait till
after the lawsuit no it was after the
lawsuit and you purchased it back yeah
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time